now that you've risen from your bed do
you wonder why it is so late it's the
change to daylight saving time that made
you last out of the gate whatever you
woke up this morning you're just in time
to look at a timepiece guaranteed to
remain accurate absolutely for a
lifetime and then still Ben Tracy shows
a celestial timekeepers at work if
you're still grumbling about the hour of
sleep you lost this morning then pay a
visit to this modest storefront in San
Francisco because through these doors
they've got time to spare so here we
obviously have the planets this is a
more ancient way of telling time yeah
this is what's called an Ori it's it's a
planetary display so the the very inner
most one is mercury and that one's
actually made out of a piece of ground
meteorite the sun and venus are types of
calcite the earth there is a chilean
lapis these planets move in sync with
the orbits of their heavenly
counterparts they're the display of a
clock but it's hardly your grandfather's
clock the movement of the spheres marks
the passage of decades centuries even
millennia it's the prototype of a clock
designed to run for 10,000 years there
definitely seems to be like most things
two kinds of people there's the kind of
people who get it right away but then
there's a whole set of people that think
it's just crazy and it's a waste of time
you can guess which category Alexander
Rose falls into he's the director of the
long now foundation a group dedicated to
elongating the attention span of the
human race and it's no small irony
they've set out to break our habit of
clock watching by building well a clock
why do we need that change in
consciousness if you did a really short
sense of time then you have a really
small sensible as possible the clock
project is the brainchild of one of the
biggest brains around Danny Hillis he
built his first computer in grade school
and went on to design some of the first
supercomputers
today everyone from molecular biologists
to atomic bomb designers crunch their
numbers on his lightning-fast machines
Hill is proposed a 10,000 year clock as
an antidote to all that speed so if we
look at a problem like global warming
world hunger it's pretty impossible
problem if you try to solve it and say a
congressional budget cycle or something
like that but if you ask are we going to
solve those problems over the next
thousand years absolutely humans have
come a long way in the last 10,000 years
and will probably go a long way in the
next indeed the 10,000 year timepiece is
inspired by the age of these pottery
pieces among the earliest artifacts of
our modern agricultural civilization
proposed designs for the full-scale
clock call for it to tower 60 feet high
and be nestled into the side of a
mountain in Eastern Nevada powered by
the Sun and built to the specifications
of a deep-space probe Alexander Rose
says the clock will be engineered to
keep on ticking without human help one
thing we do know about all civilizations
is that none of them have lasted so
we're trying to design for all of those
all of those eventualities but should
some future visitor find the clock and
turn its crank
why on earth is a clock burrowed inside
a mountain need bells well the idea is
that people come and visit it and the
reason we wanted a different sequence
each day is to give each group of people
that visited a unique experience and to
make that time their time the latest
prototype sports wheels 8 feet in
diameter nearly a half ton each and Rose
himself bring some weighty
qualifications to the project when he's
not tinkering with clocks he's battling
bas his robotic gladiators made him a
favorite on the cable series battle bots
amazingly it had a lot of a lot of
parallels in that when you're building
things to be destroyed at their fastest
in three minutes you learn about
destructive modes of all kinds of pigs
so it was kind of an accelerated aging
chamber that battle box that we worked
in building a clock to stand the test of
time certainly won't come cheap millions
have already been spent and millions
more are needed but by dipping into his
own deep pockets and those of his
high-tech friends Danny Hillis hopes to
keep his bid for immortality on a tight
schedule well I'm only going to live for
so long so that's the real deadline for
the south the real deadline for the
project